what were most the parents doing during
this time I realized that some of them
had said you know we weren't lawyer on
retainer type of people you know we
would just sort of relied on the
goodness of others and and and family
helped us but what were they doing
during these years that their kids were
denied release over like minor things
things that well all of the parents
tried to like once their kid was in they
kind of tried to do something they would
make phone calls but perhaps they didn't
make enough calls I mean in Hilary
trances Cayce her mother she was just
going to keep calling until someone said
they could help her but the difference
between her and the other parents was
that she was a social worker she was a
very well-educated social worker laurene
transue and she knew that when she heard
the words adjudicated delinquent she
knew what that meant she knew that her
kid was the custody and control was just
taken and there wasn't anything she
could do so she had to do something to
get her out and she just was going to
keep calling till she found someone
that's when she found the juvenile Law
Center in Philadelphia which turned out
to be their heroes
you